in this video you're going to learn how
to solve a right triangle so what does
that mean to solve a right triangle well
it basically means that you're going to
solve for all the missing angles all the
missing sides you're going to find
pretty much everything in the Triangle
that there's three angles and three
sides you're going to find all six
pieces now you're going to be given a
couple of items whether it's an angle or
a side Etc but we have to find the
missing pieces so let's go through a
couple examples together and then I'll
have you do a couple on your own for
practice so this first problem you can
see we have a right triangle this 90
degree angle and we're given this side
angle as 27 degrees and the side across
over here is 4. so we want to go ahead
and find the missing size missing angles
now we know in a triangle all the angles
add up to 180 right
but if it's a right triangle the two
acute angles have to add up to 90
because 90 Plus 90 gives you the 180. so
if we do 90 minus 27
that's going to give us 63 degrees for
this angle B up here
now let's say we want to solve for this
missing side right here this is going to
be side B which is across from angle B
so what we're going to do is let's use
this angle that they gave us I like to
start off with the initial quantities
just because they're exact they're not
rounded if you made a mistake you don't
carry that mistake forward so what I do
is I position myself here at the angle
27 degrees and I say what trig function
sine cosine or tangent ties together the
opposite side and the adjacent side well
you can see opposite and adjacent that's
the tangent TOA so we're going to do is
we're going to say the tangent of the
angle tangent of 27 degrees equals the
ratio of the opposite divided by the
adjacent it's always that second letter
divided by the third so that's going to
be 4 over B now there's a property in
proportions where you can switch these
guys on the diagonal so you can put B
here in tangent of 27 here B e over 1 is
just equal to B so we're getting 4
divided by the tangent of 27 degrees
let's go to the calculator and see what
that comes out to
if you don't like that method you can
cross multiply you can do 1 times 4 is 4
B times tangent of 27 and then divide by
tangent of 27 to get B by itself but in
this case it looks like this is coming
out to 7.85
so that's this missing side right here
and now all we're left to solve for is
this hypotenuse and again I'm going to
go back to the original numbers just
because see this is a little bit rounded
so I'm going to say what trig function
ties together this angle this side and
the hypotenuse well we've got opposite
and hypotenuse that is going to be our
sine ratio so we're going to say the
sine of 27 degrees is equal to the
opposite side 4 over the hypotenuse
which in this case this is little a
lowercase a
side a so again I'm going to use that
technique of switching these on the
diagonal so a over 1 is just equal to a
equals 4 divided by the sine of 27
degrees so let's go ahead and do that
on the calculator I'm getting 8.81
and that's it you solve the triangle you
found all the angles all the sides let's
do another example number two is a
little bit different a little bit more
challenging in the sense that they're
giving us two sides but they're not
giving us the angles
so the first thing I would do here is I
would make use of the Pythagorean
theorem since I have two sides in a
right triangle and remember the
Pythagorean theorem a squared plus b
squared is equal to c squared so we're
going to say the leg squared 8 squared
plus this side which is f so F squared
is equal to the hypotenuse squared 13
squared so we have 64 plus F squared
equals 169 subtract 64 from both sides
that's 105 and take the square root and
you can see that f is equal to the
square root of 105
that's an exact answer
we can also get a decimal approximation
here so this is about 10.25
approximately okay now let's go ahead
and solve for the angle so let's say for
example I wanted to solve for angle D so
what I do is I position myself at that
vertex at that angle and I say what trig
function ties together the opposite side
and the hypotenuse well that's the signs
the opposite over hypotenuse but when
you're solving for the missing angle you
want to use the inverse trig function so
we'd want to do the sine inverse so it's
the sine inverse that's what that minus
1 means of the opposite side 8 over the
hypotenuse 13. so let's see what that
comes out to you might have to press the
second key on your calculator to get
that sine inverse 8 divided by 13. that
comes out to about I'm going to round to
the nearest degree here because it's
almost 38 degrees so this is 38 degrees
if I want to solve for angle F I know
these two acute angles have to add up to
90 so that means that angle F must be 90
minus 38 which is 52 degrees and that's
it you solve it you found all the sides
all the angles let's go through two more
examples and I'll have you practice
these on your own to get some more
practice okay before we jump into these
last two examples which I like for you
to try to practice on your own first
we'll go through them together if you
like the way that I explain things and
you want to learn more about Algebra 1
or Algebra 2 or college algebra check
out the links in the description below
I've got a couple of video courses there
for sale and I walk you through step by
step the important concept that you
would learn in an algebra 1 and Algebra
2 course so check those out but let's go
ahead and dive into these problems here
how would you solve this triangle how
would you find the missing angles and
the missing size
well if I was going to do it I would
notice that we have these two angles
here I can easily solve for this third
angle by knowing that the triangle
angles add up to 180 that's the triangle
angle Sum Theorem so I can also do a
shortcut I can say 90 minus 43 is
47 degrees because the two acute angles
have to add up to 90 Plus 90 is 180. now
let's go ahead and solve for let's say
this side over here lowercase G that PSI
G what trig function ties together the
opposite and the hypotenuse that's the
sign right so so we're going to say the
sine of 47 degrees is equal to the
opposite side G over the hypotenuse 12.
I'm going to multiply both sides by 12.
to get G by itself and let's go to the
calculator so that comes out to 12 times
the sine of 47 which is about 8.78
now all we have to do is solve for this
side lowercase H or side H again I'm
going to go back to the original numbers
which actually I use 47 but 47 was exact
sometimes when you have a rounded number
it's better to use the ones they gave
you initially and so let's go ahead and
do we'll use 47 again so we'll do
adjacent and hypotenuse which is the
cosine
okay so we're going to say the cosine of
47 degrees
equals adjacent H over hypotenuse 12. so
again we're just going to multiply both
sides by 12 to get H by itself and 12
times the cosine of 47
is 8.18
and you solve the triangle you found all
the angles all the sides
for our last problem number four how
would you do this one how would you find
all the Angles and all the sides well
let's take a look here it looks like if
I was going to do this we were given two
sides which means we can find the third
side using our Pythagorean theorem so
this is going to be 5 squared plus 12
squared is equal to B squared because
remember the angle on the side they're
like a pair capital letters the angle
lowercase is the side and we use the
same letter okay so we can have 25
plus 144
it's weird seeing B here because we
always say this is equal to c squared
right so this is 169 equals B squared
take the square root of both sides and
you can see that b is equal to 13. so
that's dismissing hypotenuse here now
let's go ahead and solve for one of the
angles let's go ahead and solve for
angle a so if we position ourself here
at angle a we see we have the opposite
side and the adjacent side opposite
adjacent is our tangent but because
we're solving for the missing angle
we're going to do the tangent inverse
of the opposite side over the adjacent
side to get the measure of angle a so
let's see what that comes out to on the
calculator again you might have to press
your inverse key your second key to get
that tangent inverse
and that's coming out to
67.38 so let's just write that down here
so 67.38
and then to find angle C because these
two acute angles are complementary they
add up to 90. I'm just going to do 90
minus 67.38 which gives us
22.62 degrees and you solve the triangle
so great job if you're able to get those
two problems if you want to learn more
about trigonometry the measurements and
triangles I've got an introduction to
trigonometry video here on YouTube I'll
put the link right there go ahead and
click on that video follow me over there
and we'll get some more practice working
with right triangle trigonometry I'll
see you there